let me jump to this story from the
post-millennial to give everybody a good
bit of optimism quote my pronouns are
USA Massachusetts Middle School tries to
make children wear Rainbow clothing for
Pride students Revolt wear red white and
blue
this video is fascinating where you have
parents Furious that these kids were
saying no to Pride day some kids were
chanting that their pronouns were USA
they were wearing red white and blue and
pride decorations had been torn down
parents said the hate starts at home
this is fascinating so kids at a school
revolted against what the school is
trying to impose on them and other
parents came in and blamed the the
parents of those kids I gotta tell you
that's fascinating to me
kids acting out and you're Furious and
upset but you know it is you know what
is amazing is that we're seeing more and
more of this so it's another video where
kids are in a classroom and they play a
pride video and the kids all Boo and
groan and say why are you showing this
to us and the teacher threatens them
with a quote unquote Saturday school if
they if they don't stop acting
inappropriately
I think the kids are all right I think
we're seeing this is this is cause for
hope the kids are all right the kids are
more than all right and I've known this
for a long time because I'm out on the
streets and they come up to me but I'm
going to read you guys the message I got
from a grade 10 student today
hi Chris thanks for getting back so soon
oh here it is I'm in 10th grade this has
to stop
I'm tired of going to school scared of
getting pressed because I said something
bad in a language they made up
it's not fair that they're insecure
teenagers whose parents didn't give them
enough attention who knows if that's
true but as kids why do I have to pay
for it and he told me that in advance of
this protest we had last week over the
PA system to the whole school
they said
that if kids didn't get support for
Pride or for transition that these kids
would be likely to commit suicide or
have self-harm a child said this over
the PA system to the whole school this
is the propaganda that these kids are
receiving everywhere and when they hear
this a thousand times a year they
believe it and so when People Like Us
come along and talk Common Sense they've
been so indoctrinated by these school
systems to believe that kids are coming
to harm that they think we're the devil
but they're planning a walkout the
students now are planning a walkout next
week against their own where is this at
this is in Ottawa Canada oh wow wow but
this is happening all across the country
in Nova Scotia on June 1st 33 of
students didn't go to school the parents
withheld them to protest pride month
whoa really that's a massive yeah I mean
Canada is in serious trouble big time
yeah but we're fixing it I white people
all the time because I have faith in
humanity and I know that we're going to
get the truth out there but yes I think
we're probably the worst in the world if
you like children especially have a kind
of a
you know just a reputation for being
um like uh to
am I having a trouble with the words you
know like to say no to uh revolt against
Authority there's this whole like Punk
Counter Culture yeah whatever's popular
children are are great young people
because their brains are still like very
open to seeing what's real and what's
not now there are kids that will get
manipulated but I tell you if a school
for a year force-fed kids meatloaf and
all they did was put meatloaf propaganda
all over the school you better believe
that half a bunch of those kids are
going to be like screw Meatloaf I don't
want I don't want anything to do with
meatloaf I hate meatloaf and then you're
gonna see that with pride it's not that
it's because they hate transgenderism
gay or by they don't want to be
indoctrinated exactly they went too far
popular thing I've been bamboozled by
this 20-something generation who love
government Authority wear masks you're
evil for not wearing a mask get jabbed
do everything the government tells you
that's what all these 20-somethings are
doing yeah but I'm seeing a generational
shift with the younger kids they're
tired of this and it's beautiful well I
wonder if it's because as we often
mention conservatives are more likely to
have kids
and I think one of the reasons the left
is so panicked and desperately trying to
indoctrinate in schools is because they
know they don't have kids 20 years ago
it was like four to three for every four
conservative kids there were three
liberal kids and this means that voting
patterns are going to shift very very
very heavily now people on the right
often say Well they're going to bring in
illegal immigrants for that or whatever
and I'm like yeah but they can't vote
they they can change the census in a
decade which will favor certain urban
populations that do this but in the
short term they will not win if this is
the case right older people are are
passing on younger people are entering
voting age and there's more younger
conservatives than than left
conservative I'm sorry than left kids
and so they their only option as the
saying goes socialists don't have kids
they have yours that's their only option
yes and I've had probably 15 000
conversations out on the street my
number one allies I hate the word Ally
the people who support me the most
are black men yeah it's so rare for a
black man to have an issue with my
message which is that we shouldn't be
transitioning kids they all agree with
me the women too and Hispanic
communities and they are they are
conservative when it comes to family
they like the nuclear family yes well
you know but they've all been taught to
believe that they have to vote Democrat
as though Democrats are representing
their interests and they're not and
we're going to see a shift in this as
we've already seen happen in Florida it
is a it is a a fascinatingly white
liberal family thing to not have
families you know if you look at uh
we've talked about Shabbat and Jewish
families and how powerful that is in
protecting your kids your family and
your community from Friday sun down to
Saturday on Friday sun down to Saturday
sun down you are with your family you're
not working you're not you know they
Sabbath very seriously and uh even for
Christians going to church the these
form protective barriers for your
community from outside influences that
seek destroy you but if you look at a
lot of uh like immigrant families if you
look at as you mentioned black families
they're they're very much so uh they say
that the church is heavily involved in
politics although it's not as true as it
used to be it is fascinating that it
seems to be more so white liberal
families that are opposed to family in
general it will it's um I was going to
touch on this and you sort of mentioned
this to him but these are the views of a
very specific subsection of affluent
white people this is not something that
the black community is calling for the
Hispanic Community is calling for and
it's not something the vast majority of
white people are calling for either it's
just a very very small uh minority a
very affluent people and when you look
at BLM in the fact that they've tied it
up so closely with this gender nonsense
and they've even put a black and brown
stripe on the pride flag to try to link
these perverse sexual lifestyle choices
to being a minority in this country
becomes obvious that they really know
that they have to try as hard as they
can to get the support of these groups
and so they're going to try to do that
just by claiming it's the case and
shouting you down if you disagree with
them having a few spokespeople who are
Black Or Hispanic when in reality those
communities they don't like this right
they don't want to be called late Kinks
they don't want you trying to trans
their kid they're not taking their kid
to drag queen Story Hour this is
something white Suburban mothers with
too much time and money think makes them
special that's all that's affluenza I
mean I thought it was a joke what was
that guys affluenza was yeah no regard
for consequence some kid rich kid hit uh
and killed somebody drunk driving I
believe and they let him out and they're
like wow his problem is that he's too
affluent he's got affluenza that was an
actual thing like it's not an actual
medical condition but they purported
like it was and I'm wondering if that's
this is actually affluenza when people
get too rich and white and I'm white
people get too rich too rich what will
be the word not too white but too like
socially stable complacent yeah
complacent because it's like oh you
don't have to work to be get ahead in
society do you start looking into the
problems it's it's that uh it's that
Meme of the guy he tweets uh uh in the
and he lives in Los Angeles and he
tweets yay they're writing keep it up
look like watch the building burn then
the next day he tweets oh no they're
coming to my neighborhood get out of
here you you beasts yes this is the
party of empathy as soon as the problem
is out there you realize all this inner
crap is not that important look James
O'Keefe did this was fantastic they went
to I believe it was James they went
people's houses and they said that they
were people who were in favor of gun
control and then the people now are like
oh that's fantastic like do you support
gun control like I do absolutely and
they're like you don't own guns right
they're like no who does like can we put
aside in front of your house saying
proud proud gunless home like we oppose
guns and every person goes well well no
no you can't do that like you're
inviting criminals like what what do you
mean I thought you were in favor of gun
control that's the perfect example the
wealthy uppity people who are protected
by police will complain about police
because they don't see the problem
then later on they go oh Heaven's me oh
how can this be like that uh was it the
ice cream shop in it was it Seattle I
think you mentioned they say defund the
police and then they go out they start
losing money and now they're suing the
city because the police didn't help him
yes I've had police called on me 150
times Always by police people who say
let's defund the police yeah every time
they're the first to call the police as
soon as they see an opinion they don't
like no it's words or violence you know
well there's there's a certain kind of
person this happens to but I find this
is also true of people who uh are
wealthy and particularly when they're
very wealthy to the point where they
will never have to worry about their
material needs for the rest of their
life there is an increased emphasis on
reputation and other people's perception
of you which I think would be considered
extremely unusual if it were seen in a
poor or working class person
and then what you no longer have to
concern yourself with having your basic
needs met how you look to other people
becomes much more important and so what
happens is you want to be seen as high
status within your community but
everyone else is already very wealthy or
have their their needs taken care of and
so one way that you can signal your
superiority is by saying I care about X
Y or Z social cause and even if you're
not necessarily doing anything that
actually helps people if you claim that
you are if you say you know you're
contributing to some cause like BLM
which doesn't actually do anything
besides destroy but purports to help uh
black people and and others who are
disenfranchised then you can get this
unearned social capital and I think
that's what matters to them more than
money in many instances well thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for unseen
answered members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time